[Music]
when a person fails to keep up with
their rent on a storage unit
the contents of that locker go up for
auction people can then bid on those
items based on a mere glimpse of what's
visible from the outside
only learning what treasures lie within
after they've forked over the cash they
bid during the auction
it's a high risk high reward scenario
and that's exactly why
millions of people have tuned in to
watch amd's hit series
storage wars for years the main cast of
storage wars regularly battle it out for
hidden treasures
taking what most people would consider
junk renovating it
and selling for a profit few people
excel at this
as well as mary padian who was
introduced to viewers in storage wars
texas
before moving to the main series in
season five
known as the junkster paidion quickly
became a fan favorite for her peppy
attitude and willingness to go the extra
mile to find
amazing trinkets where's ricky
who ricky who ricky i don't even know
who you're talking about
i already psyched you out you already
forgot your partner
she'd then use her winnings from the
show to sell all kinds of idiosyncratic
objects in her store
mary's fines but before she was a
businesswoman payton was just an average
college student
provided the normal college experience
involves getting followed around
by secret service everywhere you go
let's rewind the clock to the late 90s
and early 2000s
that's when paidian attended the
university of texas at austin
eventually obtaining a photojournalism
degree in 2003.
the university of texas at austin also
happens to be the college that a certain
u.s president's daughter attended
and at the same time that padian was
there jenna bush the daughter of
president george w
bush earned her bachelor's degree in
english in 2004
a year after payton graduated given that
a bush was on the ut
austin campus during the height of
george w bush's presidency it makes
sense that there might be secret service
people walking around
but why was marypadian someone they also
followed
during a podcast interview with the
mystery men back in 2016
paidion revealed that she not only knew
jenna bush but was
also her roommate for a time when the
podcast hosts questioned whether she saw
a lot of secret service detail during
her time as bush's roomie
payton confirmed that there were a lot
of agents around to keep an eye on bush
as bush's roommate paidian naturally
ended up with secret service protection
as well
but only when she was with bush not when
she was alone
she went on to save the experience it
was crazy
but it was her life she didn't choose it
you know she was indifferent to it
it was fine but it wasn't paidian later
shared that wherever bush decided to go
the agents would follow the host then
asked what it was like to go to a
college bar requiring that kind of
protection
payton revealed that she would often
forget the secret service agents were
even around
and only when looking back on the
experience does she remember how unusual
it was
looking back on it i'm like oh my god
you know but at the time
no i didn't notice i mean their secret
service they're trained professionals
they know what to do it was just her dad
was the president i felt bad for her at
times
following graduation padian landed a job
with architectural digest
and was mentored directly by
editor-in-chief paige rentz
years later she'd returned to texas to
start mary's fines
and it seems that payton may have kept
in touch with bush over the years
or at least until fall 2013 as evidenced
by a tweet padian sent to bush
on october 31st of that year bush
tweeted a photo of her mother
laura bush holding her daughter margaret
laura mila hagar who was dressed as an
astronaut for halloween
paidion responded to the sweet picture
she is so cute jenna i can't even take
it
you know how the saying goes college
roommates who have secret service
protection together
stay together or something like that
check out one of our newest videos right
here plus even more looper videos about
your favorite reality stars are coming
soon
subscribe to our youtube channel and hit
the bell so you don't miss a single one